[موسيقى]
بعض من ركام وذكريات هو كل ما تبقى من
مبنى كان يضج بالحياه فتحت انقاذ منزلها
الذي تهاوى قبل شهرين قضت جومانا
في ازقه مدينه طرابلس تتكرر حكايات اليمه
لانهيار مبان او تصدعات تنذر بخطر وشيك
تدعون امل الى دارها التي غزت اساساتها
التصدعات وتساقطت مؤخرا اجزاء منها
والله العظيم
هكذا اذا لم تعد سقوف المنازل مرادفا
للامان بل باتت مصدر خطر يهدد حياه السكان
هذه المباني المتصدعه في مدينه طرابلس لا
تشكل استثناء اذ ينتشر امثالها على كامل
الاراضي اللبنانيه واقع دفع السلطات بعد
كارثه زلزال كهرمان مراش الى البدء بمسح
ميداني للمباني كافه تحسبا من اي مخاطر
مستقبليه
تغيب التقديرات الرسميه للمباني المتصدعه
في لبنان فيما تفيد منظمات محليه بان الاف
المباني مهدده بالسقوط ففي محيط مرفا
بيروت مئات المباني عصف بها الانفجار قبل
اكثر من عامين تم ترميم جزء منها وترك
البعض الاخر لمصير مجهول المباني بالفعل
تقادم الزمن من عمل لصيانه على الاطلاق
يعني ما في قانون بيلزم صيانه المباني
وفق معايير ومواصفات هندسيه وفنيه محدده
وهذا امر خطير عم بحكي قبل الزلازل
اما جنوبي لبنان فيتكرر المشهد رافقنا
وفدا متخصصا من البلديه لمعاينه المباني
هنا الا ان عملهم يقتصر على المسوحات لان
كلفه التحاليل فاقت طاقه السلطات المسؤوله
عن رصد المباني المتهلكه بدايه فنيه
وامكانيه علميه تفوق تفوق قدرات امكانيات
ماديه ماديه كبيره بهالموضوع هذا لحتى انه
اتمام واجراء ومتابعه الفحوصات هذه بتكلف
على المبنى الواحد اذا متعدد الادوار ما
بيكلف اقل من 5000 دولار الفحص المختبر
يتبعه تختزل هذه التصدعات واقع الحال في
لبنان مثل خطه رسميه للتعامل مع خطر يحدق
بحياه الاف المواطنين وذلك في ظل ازمه
يغيب معها التمويل لانجاز عدد من الملفات
الداهمه والتي يساهم الاستقصاء السياسي في
استفحالها كارمنج الجزيره صور جنوبيه
لبنان